to the to the afternoon session so we
don't know because I don't you know I
come from a proof state drop change it
on to my knees so we have to drive out
here so I propose that the next speaker
is body code and we crease the ticket is
the next talk is to say yes yeah
first question cool welcome back guys my
name is Morocco chef Sookie and today
we're gonna be talking about trying to
scale BFT to millions of nodes using a
project we're calling VF tree so just a
bit of motivation why are we doing this
so at cell oh we're using a proof of
stake protocol for our platform that
makes financial tools accessible for
anyone with a mobile phone and we really
like PFT because it it's really well
understood there are it's been around
for a while they're good proofs or it's
kind of liveness and safety guarantees
and so we really liked a lot of these
features but you know as I'm sure many
people here know it scales quite poorly
this means that for our purpose sake
protocol we have to do what is common
with many other protocols we have to
basically delegate stake to elect say
hundreds of validators who then perform
and the pbft consensus and this really
limits the scalability of the whole
overall system and so we wanted to look
to see if we could do something that
could really scale to the same numbers
that we're seeing in proof-of-work
networks and Bitcoin and so that was our
challenge and so bf3
it's kind of the result of that effort
and for some really really quick
background I'll go through really
quickly you know why this be a fee not
scale here's an example of some
communication showing notes achieving
consensus on the y-axis we have nodes
themselves on the x-axis we have time
and these are all the messages and this
is kind of the the oh of N squared
messages and I'm sure everyone's
familiar with that really limit the
ability for this to scale and hot stuff
released something that's really quite
elegant it basically pipelined each of
these different phases throughout the
BFG algorithm so that at each block you
only needed to do o of n messages and
you know the trade-off here is that you
don't get one block finality you have
finality only at three or maybe four
blocks but the end result is for each
actual block the communication is much
smaller so you can you can run with more
validators but can you run with millions
of validators I would argue no mostly
because at the end of the day the block
producer has to receive all of these
different signatures that you're seeing
over here this is an O of n operation
that you know will be hard both from a
bandwidth perspective and then also if
you're trying to aggregate these
signatures then it just becomes quite
expensive for one machine to be doing
all of that work and so here's just a
quick summary of the different
approaches you know what we really
wanted to look at is this best case
critical path how can we lower that so
that we could do better than then hot
stuff so in hots up case against o of n
and if you weaken the adversary kind of
model a little bit then
you know hopefully I'll convince you
that you can actually do this in the log
of n and if you can do it in log of n
then you can actually start scaling this
to quite a lot of notes and then the
trade-off too is you do use more
messages you know n log n versus n and
and that's part of the other trade off
cool so just to quickly show what this
algorithm looks like to try to convey it
I'm going to show kind of a simplified
illustrative version of it to begin with
and the the basic approach is to arrange
all of the validators as leaf nodes in a
tree to say if you have you know all of
your kind of nodes that maybe were
elected through some mistake kind of
election or you know maybe like in e 2.0
they all put in the same amount of
collateral and they all become
validators so they're all arranged down
here and and then this is a kind of a
more of a topology like a virtual tree
the inner nodes are actually and looks
like my pointer stopped working the
internodes are actually virtual nodes
composed of the it's the same validator
that was left node in one of these kind
of pairs plays the role of this parent
of these two nodes so this validator
actually also plays a role of this node
just know that node in that node
likewise this fella better plays a role
of that node and when you're looking to
all agree on a particular state
transition all the nodes all the
validators will basically aggregate
their signatures up the tree so we use
BLS signatures so that we can aggregate
them into a single constant signature
and they're basically going up this tree
and achieving unanimous consensus so
only when both parties at each level
agree do we move up the tree and in
order to track also which validators
have agreed you're also including the
range of nodes that are belong to that
signature and we do that with and
maintaining basically we're aggregating
the following tuple the block info this
aggregate VLS signature and in the first
index in the last index so that at any
point you know okay this signature here
is for these four nodes or for
validators and you keep aggregating up
until you hit a malicious node where you
can't agree with your sibling being able
to so there is a an assumption that
you're waiting in rounds for each
and so as you're going up when your
neighbors disagree you basically stop
aggregating and so in this example I'm
showing exactly where we've stopped
aggregating so in this case these two
nodes did not agree and so we stopped
here these two did agree but this one
can agree with this guy because we
stopped already here so we're gonna stop
here similarly over there and because
half of the tree here also stopped the
root cannot aggregate either and so when
this happens you basically find all of
the roots of all of the sub trees that
disagree and you perform kind of a
weighted bft algorithm and so the nice
thing about doing this is that you the
algorithm basically degenerates to B of
T which means that it's easy to reason
about it's kind of safety and liveness
properties now this alone is not enough
because it's quite easy to construct
entries in this tree where you have a
lot of disagreement and so one thing
that we do that is pretty key to the
performance is we identify all of the
nodes that agreed with the overall
two-thirds consensus that we got at the
end and for the next block or this is
actually after a window of blocks we
move the nodes that disagree to the
right and the nose that agree to the
left and so this in effect creates a
reputation system where the further you
are to the left they're more reliable
you've shown to be over time okay I'll
get to you in a sec and whenever you're
unreliable or have acted maliciously you
get kind of push to the right
what in the tree that you have the route
Alan said it's possible question they
are the ones back to militias all your
leaves are actually good let's say let's
even maybe give me 12 and then what
happens yeah so we'll get to that in
kind of the full example but I think
that the key here is that by moving
nodes to the left and by having this
design where the left node of a pair
becomes also this virtual node up here
you're basically meaning that the more
reliable nodes end up being for the left
and also higher up the tree which means
that it's harder for them to what's not
harder but it's less likely that they
will act maliciously and not propagate
this thing just from below we'll get to
what happens in those cases in a sec but
you they have to act
you're a science finding out or saying
something on capacity yeah so if they
agree they both create a signature that
signs basically
[Music]
this commitment to the block and if they
don't say anything then that's
considered a disagreement yeah but how
do you know that it might have sent a
message a team it could be malicious or
there could be a network fault and
that's considered just like with bfp
traditionally that's considered to move
on the honestly below into the last
we'll get that
we talked about this we move these nodes
there and then now basically we've moved
kind of reliable nodes with high
reputation to the left
effectively two-thirds of the tree which
means that in the happy case the
two-thirds can relatively quickly just
by kind of doing log and operations up
the tree can a great their signatures
and achieve consensus so that turns out
that there's some problems with this as
you guys have pointed out so I'm just
gonna talk through some changes to
actually make this work and also be more
performant and so the first thing is
we're not just using an arbitrary BFG
algorithm we're actually using hot stuff
here which has two benefits number one I
think you can have more disagreements
and and still be able to achieve
consensus on a block relatively quickly
but and I think this gets to maybe some
of the questions with hot stuff
basically nodes and their signatures to
the block producers so say that this
validator is the current block producer
out of all of the validators that are
leaf nodes here the roots of all of the
green trees or sub trees basically have
to send their aggregate signatures and
the aggregate ranges to that node now if
this node is malicious and may choose
not to send that signature it could also
it could choose not to send it it could
yeah nobody can do and and so that
presents a problem because now we have
you know all of these nodes
not actually getting their signatures to
the block producer and so that could
cause problems and so the way we resolve
this because we actually do log and
stages where the block producer at each
one of those stages will broadcast the
signatures the aggregate signatures that
it's received so far and if you notice
that you're not included then you have
an opportunity to correct that and I
think a strawman version of this would
be having all of the validators that
weren't included send something directly
to the validator but then you run into
the same issue that that would create a
lot of aggregating work for that
validator so instead we do this login
times and we let the children of the
node that failed to do its tasks make
the correction so now these two nodes
can send their aggregates and if one of
them is malicious this one then on the
next round these two folks would have an
opportunity
and so on going down the treatments so
in the worst case it would be login
rounds in the best case you know 2/3
majority of all the nodes would be off
to the left and would be able to
aggregate this
so there's another challenge which is a
verifiable question only the tree tears
you other nodes have path to other yeah
trees the only way of network money
right to trace the only way route for
the children I mean the ones which are
Salford those are the malicious people
then they may not even forward the
message so how is somebody else
those are lying in the other part of the
cream how will they aggregate them as
people they don't even receive because
if the topmost nodes are the managers
this is exactly the example I just gave
so in this case the top node is
malicious it received these two
aggregated signatures but it chose not
to forward it to the block producer and
so that's a problem and so to reconcile
that problem we let these two children
send their signatures if they've
detected that their signatures were not
included in the last broadcast of the
latest signatures we go down the tree
that's exactly what happened here so in
the worst case is login of these
broadcasts and and more and more these
things just have to go from these nodes
to to the buck producer so I think
though if we had a malicious adversary
that could basically affect nodes
uniformly throughout this whole tree
then it could cause some of this kind of
stress on the system adversary's were
kind of considering the other
interesting challenge here is actually
verifying those signatures so if you
receive one of these BLS are unit
signatures you have to actually
aggregate the equivalent public key of
all of those private keys that were used
to construct the signature and that can
take some time for example if we wanted
to for a million nodes I get this I
could get public key
we did some benchmarks and it takes
around three minutes on a nine nine
processor so you probably wouldn't be
able to do that on every block and so
instead
so instead each node or each validator
actually maintains a kind of public key
cache basically they can they have a
tree like this where they store all the
intermediate nodes so this means that if
they want to check a signature for this
range that they've received from someone
they already have the key that's ready
to go and paying three minutes when you
start it up is actually not that
expensive the challenge becomes when
you're actually moving these nodes left
and right once they actually act
maliciously you have to update this tree
as well and so for every node that
you're moving it's going to take log n
operations basically moving up the tree
updating the nodes and so if you move
say R nodes over then you would have to
pay our login and so the interesting
thing here now is you're basically
trading off the work that you might have
to do to verify these signatures with
the flexibility of this tree in booting
kind of these malicious nodes off to the
right where they're not going to be able
to interfere with the non malicious
nodes and so the way to do that is to
basically pick an R that is fairly big
it's basically big enough that you can
update this public key tree relatively
quickly so that you can do it within the
block period but so that you can still
move quite a lot of nodes over to the
right after they start acting
maliciously
any question
well so we we simulated some performance
results and these are some kind of
interesting outcomes of this and so the
first question we wanted to ask
ourselves is okay in the best case you
know what kind of performance could we
get what you know in the case where you
only have to do one broadcast two-thirds
of the tree are acting sufficiently
non-malicious research that we can
aggregate those signatures quickly and
you know for up to a million nodes and
if you assume Layton sees real-world
latencies and a network where you have a
million nodes kind of uniformly
distributed around the world yeah where
there's no locality between kind of your
siblings in this tree you could be all
the way across the other country across
the other side of the world then you get
kind of numbers that roughly look like
this
so not surprisingly the taller the tree
the more time it takes to kind of
aggregate and so the way to get to
numbers that become pretty compelling
for for an actual blockchain is to
increase the branching factor of that
tree and so if you increase the
branching factor to 32 then your your
tree height decreases dramatically and
you can actually get to a case where in
roughly two seconds you're able to in
that best case now you aggregate all of
these signatures so this is achieving
consensus across a million nodes without
kind of a subsampling that something
like the affinity or algorithm uses and
so to do that in two seconds is pretty
cool and then the next question that we
were looking at was around adversity
models so using a you know the typical
adaptive adversary you know this kind of
reputation system doesn't actually buy
you anything because that mercenary can
basically target
you know left-most third all the time or
maybe kind of uniformly distribute their
malicious nodes within the tree and and
really cannot cause havoc to the tree
but if you if you assume slightly weaker
assumptions and we're still working to
formalize these then you actually get
better performance and so here we were
looking at the number of messages based
on the percentage of malicious nodes
that were also malicious in the previous
block so that's what these different
lines are up here if in for the red line
if you assume that zero percent of the
previous blocks validators that of the
nodes that are malicious right now zero
percent were malicious before and it was
a different one third set that was
malicious before then basically your
adversary is able to kind of attack huge
swaths of your network with just one
block notice so as soon as you do that
the whole benefit of this tree really
breaks down and you get a lot of
messages in the case where even 90% of
the network is is reliable and only 10%
is delicious but if you start assuming
that your adversary can't actually just
attack a different section of the
network maybe you're worried about
Google Cloud going down for 12 hours or
a state actor turning off the internet
for a whole country then there's really
a lot of correlation between the
validators that went offline
because of that act and then stayed
offline afterwards it's hard for
malicious bursaries that shuts off the
internet for a whole country to then
pick basically another entire set of
validators for the next block
I have a question about this right
super position means that there are
something we thought about a bunch and I
think number one it's not that easy to
position yourself exactly where you want
to be definitely to be the most reliable
node although in the left you're
competing against all the other reliable
nodes and so it might be quite hard and
might take a very very long time to to
go all the way into these desirable
positions and secondly if you're going
to have a third of the stake of network
that comes quite expensive so in order
to be elected as a validator you need to
put up stake and so so this is
definitely quite challenging but you're
right I think this is something that
we're looking at we're interested in
kind of explore
what you just said right because I think
about what you're saying is you can
assume that the network is adversarial
performance becomes difficult and the
second thing they're saying is that
really performance under actually third
party knows is miserable again anywhere
there are again lots of papers but that
opens up the question of well if you're
going to relax the assumptions you do we
continue having the other machine right
can we actually make the critical path
shorter yeah that's the interesting
and so just to summarize on this slide
you know once you get down to an
anniversary that can only change say 10%
of the malicious nodes from one block to
another which is still pretty pretty big
then your number of messages that you
have to send really drops dramatically
and starts to look a lot more starts to
look a lot better than than what you'd
be getting with hot stuff
maybe interesting kind of thing to
evaluate which we haven't done yet is to
just look at with a million nodes if you
had kind of the this one third malicious
nodes uniformly distributed through the
tree just how bad is it in that case I
mean it would generate to something
that's still better than hot stuff and
so our assumption was always that it
probably will result in maybe a five or
a ten minute block and that adversary
will only be able to do that once
afterwards
those nodes would be booted out or a few
times in some window and and so that's a
very expensive in a proposition for
someone they have to invest a lot of
money they have to get their nodes into
the exact position and then they can
only really slow down the network just
for maybe an hour or maybe hopefully
less so one thing that we're interested
in looking at is actually trying to
figure out exactly what what is that
worst-case performance just how bad is
it and and I think my based on some of
the other work we've done my guess is
that it will be actually quite minimum
what you can do that's it and if you
like this talk one quick shout out so if
you haven't heard of sello
where proof is take protocol with a
interesting new like client that uses
snarks to prove the headers are part of
the chain so you can sync as Ally client
without downloading all your headers we
also have a decentralized PKI that maps
hashes the phone numbers to public keys
which means you can find each other
easily by phone number and transact
easily and securely I also have a stable
coin platform that allows for the
creation of multiple stable tokens and
critically you can pay for gas with
tokens so you can actually transfer
steel
so any of this sounds interesting next
week we're gonna announce our
incentivize test net everything SLO is
food food theme and so we're launching
our incentivize test net called the
great celos takeoff it's named after the
Great British Bake Off and so if you
like tinkering with chains then
definitely keep an eye out for it that's
it thank you
[Applause]